Resuelve para "x"
y nos dicen que
por un lado,
"5x" menos 3 es menor que 12
y satisface también que
"4x" más 1 debe ser mayor que 25.
Entonces vamos a hacerlo como lo hemos estado haciendo, vamos a resolver cada una por aparte,
y después nos acordamos
que debe cumplir ambas
gracias a esta conjunción "y"
por la palabra "y".
¿Muy bien,
entonces vamos a empezar,
de este lado tenemos
"5x" menos 3 es menor que 12,
así que lo primero que se me ocurre es,
para ir despejando la "x", es
sumar 3 de ambos lados...
sumamos 3 de ambos lados
y estos se cancelan
y me queda
"5x" es menor que 12 más 3
que son 15.
Muy bien, ahora para despejar la "x"
podemos dividir todo entre 5
y notemos,
que como 5 es un número positivo
no le pasa nada a la desigualdad,
simplemente se queda igual
¿verdad?
Así que no tenemos
ningún problema con ello,
vamos a dividir entre 5,
estos se cancelan y me queda
que "x" es menor que 15 entre 5,
que es 3,
vamos a ver
qué pasa del otro lado,
del otro lado tenemos,
"4x" más 1
debe ser mayor que 25
entonces restamos 1 de ambos lados,
restamos 1 de ambos lados,
estos se cancelan y me queda
"4x" debe ser más grande que 25  -1,
que son 24,
Nuevamente,
4 lo podemos dividir,
dividimos todo entre 4,
como es positivo
no altera el signo de la desigualdad,
estos se cancelan
y me queda que "x" es más grande
que 24 entre 4 que es 6
Muy bien, entonces ahora nos acordamos
que tenemos aquí un "y"
así que esto debe cumplirse,
"x" es menor que 3 Y "x" es mayor que 6,
y aquí en este momento
yo estoy casi seguro que tu cerebro
ya debe estar pensando que
esto está muy raro,
por que "x" tiene que ser menor que 3
y debe ser al mismo tiempo mayor que 6.
Vamos a ver cómo se grafica esto.
Tenemos nosotros
la recta real,
¿ok?
La recta numérica
digamos que por aquí
digamos anda el 3
¿ok?
y lo que tenemos de ésta, de esta de aquí,
es que "x" debe ser menor que 3
¿Ok? Entonces
"x" no puede ser 3
y nos tomamos
todos los que están a la izquierda.
Por otro lado tenemos
"x" mayor que 6.
Entonces si aquí anda el 6,
tomamos el 6, no lo incluimos
y nos vamos todo hacia la derecha,
entonces
que "x" sea menor que 3
y "x" sea mayor que 6
implica que se deben... debe haber algún momento
en el que se encimen estas dos,
estas dos regiones,
sin embargo, no tenemos esa situación
y por lo tanto podemos concluir
que no hay una solución.
No hay solución...
solución.